insanity is something odd something that
you're not really able to grasp until
you've stared it in the eye either in
the eye of a mad killer or in your own
reflection welcome to the asylum
nowadays the asylum is a shadow of its
former self
long ago the crota's pren asylum held
violent and twisted minds that scared
even the most seasoned physician today
it is part of the realm of the entity
where survivors only get a taste of what
patients endured every day the nurse is
a former orderly that worked day and
night with the most distorted minds ever
encountered but now she roams the realms
of the entity searching for survivors
the nurse uses an old bone saw as her
main weapon stabbing at anything that
crosses her path it inflicts not just
pain but also horror as you know what
it's being used for
the nurses power is called blink which
makes it able to teleport in a straight
line she can cross through walls
survivors and other objects with a
little skill you can even chain several
smaller blinks for travel even longer
distances the nurse has grown accustomed
to blood and she can sense and feel an
injured survivor from afar so try not to
get hurt and whether you should help
someone or not is not an easy call the
nurse comes with three perks and the
first one is called stride stride or
makes breathing even more audible as
survivors get hurt
so even if you manage to flee after you
got hit it's easier for the nurse to
find the second perk is Vanetta phobia
every time a survivor is hooked dying or
injured survivors are punished by
slowing down sabotaging repairing and
healing this forces survivors to work as
a team the third and final perk is a
nurses call this unlocks the potential
in the nurses or a reading capability so
all survivors trying to heal or our
being here to have stronger auras making
you easy prey as you tend to your wounds
near is of Swedish descent and is a
tagger and a bit of a troublemaker in
her early teens she started to rebel and
her parents felt that she lacks that
thing that makes everyone else normal
but as history has taught us this is
just a case of parents that just don't
understand
near has spent a lot of time on
skateboards and dodging cops so she's
used to moving fast without being seen
and she has the balance of an alley cat
near comes with three perks where the
first one is phallus lambda as near
falls long distances she doesn't lose
her balance
this makes fling even easier as she can
just keep going after a drop the second
perk is urban evasion nears walking
speed in crouch mode is increased this
makes it easier for her to sneak away
fast but still remain hidden the third
and last perk is street lights nears
consumption rate of items is reduced
making everything last a bit longer as
you enter the asylum it might take a
while until your mind adjusts after that
it's up to you to figure out
you're part of the staff or one of the
patients
the last breath is released on the 18th
of August let us know in the comments
what you think about it